Castle Crashers with manga mix 7 toes
Kenda
man sorry I thought I saw something as a
kid never mind five all of you know I
think second I figure out how to use
magic that whole thing will just turn
the whole thing around
I'm telling you on the keyboard it was
efore me I don't know what it is for you
now press W Captain Planet kinda we're
gonna win now with ice magic yeah now
use that power these the rain ha ha I
won I won
thank you you down again he's coming
after you Yami ornate oh by the way you
dust it's super effective
I'm skinnies total wreck resistant
personal video
last time I played Pokemon was like
pokemon red
so you need it hi babies GP challenge I
have no idea
very Blastoise last noise I think that I
think I might have picked that one
maybe that's the water one right yeah
I'm not doing anything by the way on
this this guy we've done more damage
from the neighbor tongue I think no God
he's ever be how do we stop him from
doing tornado douche no Friesen I killed
Oh as soon as you kill one of the other
game he just pops up again CPR to the
rescue okay alright okay we got it yeah
something amazing just crossed my night
what even if we keep losing and losing
and losing
we'll keep leveling up from doing damage
to these little guys stroke eventually
will be so strong there'll be no way we
can lose okay it's science Wow was worth
it on the button I don't even know what
Y is
with with but W ha I knocked him down
lose huzzah
he's always got the hot tub how long
does anybody know ok ok let's give this
one more try maybe yeah you went down oh
sorry sorry I keep your control all
right here we go
now just stay back you guys oh ok that
was a crack next one say we did it
getting better just gotta figure out
what button it is for everyone's they
know oh I'll do pretty good on this fact
what's the button to revive people oh it
is I try sir do you know what but it is
to make your character do this attack
yeah I do
mine's the W one for the hop all right
yeah ok all right where you get this
yes more powerful for when we left
because I'm already down health again
those stupid snowballs honey I still
love I was distracted by the money okay
okay well Mach we have money can't we
spend our money on something nice you
might have healing potions in your
inventory as well you can scroll through
it
ha ha in fact we should go and buy
healing questions from the shop then
come back here we go yeah good thank you
I'm just gonna run in circles okay - my
electricity oh my god
Oh God
cuz I got help okay defense can you take
points away how do we get to the shop I
think we might have to carry more
Oh gonna poison you
don't worry it won't hurt no game audio
it'll just be I got no defense on that
ha ha I got my electricity now the whole
thing time yeah David Beth okay so where
is his place here this one yes no no
wait no oh it's down here oh that's we
can get weapons in this place why it's
nice oh okay that makes more sir
Oh what that you know we have money
that's okay we this is just all the
weapons we've found you can change for
sniffers dance oh yeah by healing
potions there are some good weapons over
here wow this one's like obscene good I
want this I can't I can't equip that hit
the tag button on it
okay no you won't let me know though the
other penguin oh yeah there's nothing
this goes for a while I'll be conceding
else back here unless know if unlock
stuff right okay how do i sprint
DoubleTap know how many figure out how
to grunt this big old hammer yeah no I
won't let you woman it may because I
don't know yeah I can't grab this one I
then it tells me what button to press is
why just a big circle appears over here
like oh hello I was a waste of time
all right yay hey I got a new weapon oh
good grasp right now is that the only
thing here the end there's the goat oh
this is no no I don't like you yeah me
ah how do you know what is he like you I
don't know I have an animal oh there's
no animal back here aha besides me oh I
think there's a level level cap for that
one like a minimum no way I'm the lowest
level here yeah okay so where's where
can we get home castle which one home
castle yes it should be hey guys with
that there's a store I'll go wait if I
exit to map would do it yeah exiting the
map
hey if we go back in now and we go luck
it's not here either
I guess it is forward dad I get to map
maybe someone maybe it's maybe it's this
one maybe this one that oh yes by the
music how'd you play it oh you first X
the X for me anyway
I've just bought five of them so they're
full healthy stores and you can drink
them when you're down so it's the one
that does this all right I've got myself
a comp oceans guys oh I'm bashing every
button ah hey hey you got three of them
I said I got one
okay good good now exit to map yes yes
and we'll try the boss one more time one
more time of our time so so much editing
this game coming I feel it all right
here we go
I got no defense
final boss music oh you don't hear
that's right don't hate don't hear it
all it's really good this is probably
the best soundtrack I could turn up my
speaker volumes and have it wade through
my mic that'd be great competition yeah
anything like your singing I don't think
is that great you can't hit them at all
yeah be nice let me let a real man show
how to swing a hammer and this isn't a
hammer on teriyaki he's doing the rain
dance yay the thing that's a minim is a
stupid little goats not gonna stay on
after this yeah all right hang on wait
maybe what what thing does agility
affect what what's that what ability
oh I'm really wailing on him dude I'm
destroying him seriously I do do a lot
of damage with all this strength he
doodoos it maybe the problem was you
know that I never actually got up in his
face and hit him last year
thank you just watch it I'm gonna that's
all I know how to do it's hard to even
tell that I'm hitting anything
I'm just so pressing X in all grief and
I think the best Loken this guy how do I
use a poacher well first you hit right
bull until you guys find that I'm
actually useful okay yet really hurt no
you're gonna win actually Emma yeah
you're welcome then
alright go where is he he's over there I
got it Hey oh yes what type of egg yeah
yeah yeah congratulations AMI
I did what you got a green guy now I got
to go oh my god here the crap out of me
Oh some of them are nice to like fall
scary horror game I played I could only
imagine well if I mean to big pandas
came windmilling out of the right side
of the screen at me in real life I would
be very scared animals in the forest
why why why is this happening
Oh she'll die we all just stand right
here that's what I should be doing I
should just always have my shield up and
then just whack okay oh the shield
I'm not telling you actually this is
surprisingly effective I'm gonna keep
doing this forever but I've found my
calling that Yami can is dying a potion
for good
where you going secret cave Jimmy watch
as I use my pretty head you maybe I
gotta be mad poisonous why isn't it
poison it damn right hang on
so believe I'm doing something to it no
no I tried my hardest guys it didn't
work battle soon yep okay what's that
thing the lady's pretty ladies Oh Oh
snake he's mine I don't know
yes yes all right
how does it lick us from behind
I can't even get close enough to hit it
you can do like a that's why they won
during the game how did I get poisoned
and I got this thing come here ah
defending stops you from being licked I
killed it with muscles ah he putted man
King you're here finally thanks so you
Sam time he's like oh good primal
instincts bust dad if there's any gold
on the ground how long have you been
going here is this a good place to stop
yes the next level okay so go one more
if you want let's go okay I'm enjoying
myself just the math here it's wonderful
oh nice wait I got nothing Wow where the
hell are we have to do with the cave we
can't get in here yet we have to keep
continuing our creeper fields oh these
flowers look low chair back is a stinger
here I hate my school my biggest fear I
have a horse I'm lost
yeah most terrifying and scariest thing
ever no I saw a moth food size of my
fist one time nothing on the ground and
then it jumped and ate my face off just
like all moths will do if you let them
watch smokes videos what you're looking
at is a skillet since you just Photoshop
to face I'm like handsome jack you know
if in a lot of ways hi-ho silver away
how are you level eight what are these
things anyway wearing sexting masks jean
skirt 364 thanks I will eat you she's a
physics student at the local college
they thought it'd be an easy a are you
having these things and get shot oh I
was gonna jump right off oh yeah oh nice
yeah can you get the good side get me
come on yeah me oh I got it see I can
scream at it I'm second place means I'm
amazing
I cut my spirit even direction that I
really care about oh they have
lightsabers steam achievements are
serious business brah
Julia my steam achievements brick I'll
be looking fading this village he's like
Jedi's force just use your arrows
Legolas this has been Castle Crashers
with megaminx 7 toss can
stick around for part three bye-bye